[Musica]
come state tardi sono le 10 io ve lo
confesso non sto benissimo ma non è per
l'ansia di stare qui e che io c'ho
voglia di litigare stasera di aperto io
ho voglia di litigare
però non mi piace sentirmi solo la
voglio sapere se sono l'unica quindi
adesso vorrei fare un micro sondaggio vi
chiedo di chiudere gli occhi e di alzare
la mano
se pensate che non si possa più dire
niente va via senza timidezza
avete anche bevuto e mangiato ieri sera
molta più gente alzato la mano li rivedo
qualcuno timido ok va bene forse qui
questa sera ci troviamo davanti a
persone che hanno fatto tanto yoga che
stanno molto bene che sono molto sereno
e valli fuori cioè tantissima gente che
pensa che non si possa più dire niente e
io sono qui per dimostrarvi a voi che
non avete alzato la mano alle persone
che ci seguono in streaming che vi
sbagliate
ve l'ho detto che avevo voglia di
litigare
quindi sono da qui a dirvi che vi
sbagliate però la verità che a me
litigare mi piace tantissimo mi piace da
matti perché quando si litiga si possono
dire cose che si pensano veramente
dedicare profondamente liberatorio è una
cosa terribile perché si offendono le
persone con le parole le persone si
offendono abbiamo un potere nella nostra
bocca e lo possiamo utilizzare per
offendere le persone però la verità è
che è profondamente liberatorio è così
però adesso che sto diventando grande e
devo anche far finta che sto diventando
un'adulta che sto imparando l'arte del
compromesso che sto imparando a stare
zitta con il momento di stare zitta però
come scrittrice
io lo so che quello che mette in moto
con storia e quello che si chiama
incidente scatenante nei manuali di
sceneggiatura c'è scritto così che al
minuto 5 di un film deve arrivare
l'incidente scatenante cioè non la
chiacchierata scatenante non il tè con i
biscotti scatenante
l'incidente scatenante perché il
conflitto genera narrazione
insomma avete capito mi piace tantissimo
litigare ma ho capito che c'è qualcosa
dentro di me che mi impedisce di farlo
devo capire perché devo capire perché
non sono
unica perché so che c'è tanta gente che
si sente come se ci fosse qualcuno da
qualche parte che gli vuole mettere un
cerottone gigante sulla bocca per
impedirle di esprimere le proprie parole
che gli vuole lavare la lingua col
sapone questa cosa genera tantissima
rabbia io penso che il problema con il
politicamente corretto sta nel fatto che
dire quello che si pensa nel profondo
che non si può dire sia profondamente
liberatorio quindi questa cosa o di
farsi lavare lingua col sapone forse
qualcuno di voi l'ha provato veramente a
scuola non so se era una leggenda che
raccontavano delle maestre di un tempo
che utilizzavano le punizioni corporali
però per chi è nostalgico dei bei tempi
erano momenti in cui non si poteva dire
le parolacce ma si poteva finalmente
dire [ __ ] si poteva dire [ __ ] si
poteva dire handicappato sulle donne non
mi soffermo ma adesso adesso non si può
più dire niente adesso dobbiamo dire a
persona di colore adesso dobbiamo dire
disabile adesso dobbiamo dire
omosessuale alle donne non possiamo più
dire niente perché sono e cad calling
non possiamo nemmeno più dire che sono
tutta una razza il punto che forse
c'erano altre parole per definire queste
categorie di persone perché erano delle
parole offensive e si riteneva che
queste persone non avessero la
possibilità a esprimere i propri
sentimenti non potevano averne fino a
non molto tempo fa gli europei
ritenevano che le persone di colore
fossero malapena degli umani quindi
forse potevano avere dei sentimenti ma
sicuramente non l'abilità di pensare e
per troppo tempo la parola disabile è
stato sinonimo di persona con scarse
capacità intellettive ma la vera
delusione sono gli omosessuali cioè
tendenzialmente stanno in piedi sulle
proprie gambe hanno la pelle bianca
potrebbero scappo tar sel che fanno
mettono i fatti loro in piazza anziché
vergognarsi
la vergogna la vergogna al minimo comune
denominatore di queste categorie di
persone persone che non potevano
rispondere allo stese perché dovevano
vergognarsi di quello che erano è invece
un certo punto hanno cominciato a dire
beh sapete che c'è
ma io perché mi devo vergognare di
essere quello che sono e così hanno
cominciato a manifestare i propri
sentimenti e così hanno cominciato le
donne a pensare a parlare ea scrivere
adesso eccomi
su questo palco a spiegarvi perché
urlare una ragazza dall'altro lato della
strada a bella non è esattamente un
complimento e che magari potrebbe farla
sentire il disagio e attraversare la
strada
non so se avete presente instagram
facebook ci avete fatto caso che le
donne non fanno altro come interessi
cuoricini si dicono come sei bella mores
e stupenda tesoro mio sei pazzesca ma
avete mai sentito una donna urlare
queste cose è un'altra donna
camminando per strada mai perchè lo
sanno che dire una cosa del genere
magari urlata da un'altra donna potrebbe
farla sentire a disagio perché c'è modo
in maniera ad esprime di complimenti a
urlare per strada non lo è perché ancora
una volta non è un complimento ma è un
modo per utilizzare la propria parola
esercitando un potere e l'intuito
femminile è anche questo
ma il punto quindi avrete capito è che
non è che con il politicamente corretto
non si può più dire niente e che si può
parlare con un criterio consapevole del
contesto anche e soprattutto perché il
politicamente corretto
non esiste è un'invenzione della stampa
conservatrice la minaccia alla libertà
di parola non proviene la che
timidamente saltando la mamma e sta
cominciando a richiedere di utilizzare
delle parole diverse per parlare di
certe categorie la minaccia la libertà
di parola sta in quelle categorie di
persone che invece li hanno sempre
oppresse che hanno utilizzato il proprio
potere per silenziare per marginalizzare
e che adesso dall'alto delle proprie
reti televisive dei propri giornali dei
consigli di amministrazione
urlano addirittura che non si può più
dire niente se la prendono con persone
che al limite possono parlare dallo
strapuntino di internet dal proprio
profilo di twitter che è l'ultima
frontiera del web della comunicazione io
allora sono arrivata a pensare che è un
problema di marketing cioè il
politicamente corretto meriterebbe un re
branding nome più fico allora pensato
popolarmente giusto e ho detto che il
nome di merda diciamolo in inglese vuol
dire popolarmente giusto cioè e la
giustizia richiesta dal popolo la
giustizia richiesta da quelle persone
alla base della piramide sociale che
tradizionalmente sono state silenziate o
press the private dei propri diritti
però succede a un certo punto che queste
categorie diciamo così privilegiate che
però tradizionalmente invece si sono
sentite dalla parte degli oppressi
adesso stranamente non riversano la
propria rabbia nei confronti delle
categorie degli oppressori
ma nei confronti nelle categorie degli
oppressi strillando la dittatura del
politicamente corretto
e questo per me è un fatto molto curioso
e quindi ho cominciato a pensare perché
succede questo
non so se ci avete fatto caso ma
periodicamente esce qualche articolo di
giornale in cui ci vengono a dire che
vogliono cancellare via col vento
vogliono cancellare biancaneve ei sette
nani vogliono cancellare shakespeare
ora io non so l'ultima volta che avete
visto via col vento non so che voglia
abbiano i vostri figli e le vostre
figlie di ascoltare la storia di una
matrigna che tenta di far uccidere la
propria figliastra perché la ritiene più
bella di lei e non so nemmeno l'ultima
volta che siete andati a teatro a
sentire shakespeare però probabilmente
lo avete studiato a scuola quindi mi fa
un po rosicare l'idea che i vostri figli
invece non debbano gettare il sangue e
studiarlo urta un po il sistema nervoso
no
l'idea che vogliono levare le fiabe
della nostra infanzia ai nostri bambini
vi fa incazzare il fatto che un film è
un'opera d'arte possa essere messo in
discussione la rabbia la rabbia che
avete addosso che porta a condividere
quelle articoli quegli articoli
diventano virali perché è il conflitto
che crea la narrazione ma è una
narrazione tossica in questo caso
infatti gratta gratta e scopre in un
attimo che non è che vogliono eliminare
via col vento vogliono riproporlo con un
cartello che spiega il contesto storico
in cui è stato prodotto quel film non
vogliono cancellare biancaneve ei sette
nani ma ci si interroga sull'opportunità
di inserire una fiaba così cupa
ricordiamo c'è un tentativo di omicidio
in un parco a tema dedicato ai bambini
nessuno vuole cancellare checks
ma degli studenti e delle studentesse di
un'università hanno chiesto di includere
nel corso di studi di letteratura anche
degli autori che non fossero europei
perché c'erano è vero anche fuori
dall'europa si produceva letteratura
ora io voglio fare una nota per
ringraziare gli organizzatori del the
talk per avermi messo dopo il prete
perché io sto per darvi una notizia
scioccante e cioè che mettere in
discussione i classici si può fare è che
anche l'antico testamento a un sequel
si chiama nuovo testamento vedete i
classici sono l'espressione di una
categoria dominante quella che ha
l'istruzione e mezzi necessari per
diffondere questa cultura per prepararla
per cristallizzarla in effetti classici
sono proprio la fotografia di un
determinato momento storico ed è come
tale che li dobbiamo prendere
sostanzialmente a studiarli vuol dire
fare filologia comparata
nessuno vuole dire che gli affreschi di
pompei vadano cancellati però possiamo
riconoscere che sono bidimensionali e
che solo 1200 anni dopo è arrivato
giotto introdurrà il concetto di
prospettiva
potete ancora andare a pompei ad
ammirare questi affreschi 2000m e
qualche lezione vulcanica dopo sono
ancora lì non ve li toglie nessuno non
si tratta di cancellare classici si
tratta di aumentare la quantità di
classici si tratta di metterle in
discussione
ecco allora ho capito una cosa queste
categorie di persone di cui sopra volee
che si sono tradizionalmente sentite
dalla parte degli oppressi adesso si
sentono che non possono più dire niente
perché sentono che qualcosa sta
cambiando che non hanno più l'egemonia
culturale di cui sopra perché come vi
dicevo all'inizio a me piace moltissimo
litigare è successo molto spesso
ultimamente che io mi trovassi seduto a
tavola bere uno spritz magari con delle
persone molto simile a me che però
magari erano nei maschi bianchi
eterosessuali gender cioè si riconoscono
di genere che gli è stato assegnato alla
nascita a volte accompagnati da donne
bianche intero sessuali estenderli
innamorate dei loro non questo diciamo è
un dettaglio è bastato niente a farle
saltare su con questo tono di voce a
quota mi.to a casa il calcio sa non si
può più dire niente proprio con questo
tono di voce non con questo mostro letto
un po acuto
mi fa lasciava veramente un po così però
litiga votato politicata spritz dopo
space ho capito qual era il problema
queste persone sentivano di non poter
più dire niente perché non sapevano più
che cosa dire perché si sentivano
improvvisamente nella loro coltissima
visita sprovviste delle parole
necessarie da utilizzare nella società
che sta cambiando
ecco che cos'è che genera tantissima
rabbia non avere le parole vedete se io
non avessi amato litigare così tanto non
sarei mai arrivata a questa conclusione
però ancora una volta notiamo come il
conflitto genera racconto perché quello
che succede davanti a me seduta ad un
tavolino con uno spezzone replica in
piccolo di quello che sta succedendo
nella società dove c'è una frangia di
categorie oppresse incazzate con una
trama invece di persone che sono la
categoria degli oppressori
ecco io penso che noi in questo momento
in realtà abbiamo un enorme privilegio
abbiamo le norme privilegio di vedere un
cambiamento storico che sta prendendo
atto sotto i nostri occhi categorie fino
ad oggi silenziate o inascoltate stanno
finalmente prendendo la parola e ho
detto specificatamente stiamo vivendo il
privilegio perché credo anche me
naturalmente in questa categoria
perché pur appartenendo in parte a delle
categorie oppresse perché sono donna
perché sono omosessuale appartengono
anche a delle categorie molto
privilegiate perché sono bianca perché
ciò non sono scesi gender perché sono
abili e perché sono anche borghese
insomma mi trovo all'incrocio fra
oppressioni e privilegi e come me tutti
voi ci troviamo all'intersezione di
queste categorie non è una gara a chi è
più ostiche non è una gara a chi è più
figo si tratta di capire dove ci
posizioniamo su questa scacchiera nel
mondo e prendere consapevolezza il primo
passo perché ci permette di capire dove
si trovano gli altri e le altre e qual è
il loro punto di vista sul mondo
vedete noi questa sera ci troviamo in
una location veramente molto speciale
perché questo il castello svevo
costruito da federico ii che eravamo
curiosissimo gli prese una volta la
curiosità di sapere quale fosse la
lingua che avrebbero parlato gli esseri
umani in natura dunque fece prendere 12
trovatelli e trovatele le piace portare
al castello non questo
gli affidò a delle balle che le
allattavano le curavano le scaldavano le
facevano a dormire però il personale non
parlava assolutamente con questi bambini
sapete a quale con cui sono rivolte di
riccò secondo nessuna perché tutti i
bambini morirono prima di compiere un
anno
l'assenza di comunicazione uccide gli
esseri umani
peraltro federico ii anno riuscito a
scoprire che leo che parlavano di esseri
umani perché noi ci mettiamo mediamente
mille giorni per imparare esprimerci in
maniera corrente però più i bambini
ascoltano e meglio imparano a parlare
anche se le persone bilingue ci mettono
un pochino di più per imparare a parlare
perché devono servire due lingue
contemporaneamente però una volta che le
imparano le ferma più nessuno perché
quello che è stato un ritardo nei primi
anni della loro vita
se continuano ad utilizzarlo se
continuano a parlare la seconda lingua
si trasforma in un vantaggio ora non
importa quante lingue vi insegnano
quando siete piccoli quando siete
piccole
il punto è che quante più parole
impariamo quanto più ascoltiamo tanto
meglio
riusciamo ad esprimerci quindi il mio
consiglio per questa serie di continuare
a essere come quei bambini e quelle
bambine continuiamo ad ascoltare per
imparare a parlare di più e meglio con
chiunque
grazie